a neighborhood cleared out after real
estate company fisher brothers bought
out the area for a new project it's west
of the i-15 and sahara behind palace
station victoria saha gives us a closer
look at what may be next
demolition has already started for many
homes in this neighborhood by richfield
and milo way this new project by the
fisher brothers has families searching
for a new place to live
[Music]
what was once a neighborhood with dozens
of ranch style homes is now boarded up
and fenced off as the fisher brothers
company dives into a new project
the clark county assessor's website
shows dozens of homes owned by the
company i spoke to a resident who did
not want to be identified but he says he
was living in one of those homes now
fenced up before he was told to leave
earlier this summer they only gave us
like two months to get out i was like
what the heck like you know i mean like
our lease was our lease wasn't even over
or any of that the resident tells me he
still had four months left on his lease
but the company moved him to another
rental property having kids everything
you gotta find a place to live not too
far from this new project stands area 15
also owned by the fisher brothers on
their website they describe owning 75
acres off the las vegas strip which
consists of industrial office and
residential space in an email to 8 news
now they say they plan to turn the space
into over 1300 apartments ranging from
studio to three bedrooms retail options
office space and open space for dining
and walking tenants say whatever may
come out of this project they hope it
was worth the hassle of having them move
out reporting near 15 in sahara victoria
saha 8 news now
victoria did reach out to the city of
las vegas they told her the planning
committee has not yet received a
proposal for the project christian